[Applause]
yeah for example here's a book right
here I don't know why this didn't sell
it's called flightless birds arranging a
flight an ostrich right there knee he
wants to fly I hope he gets first class
it's this book I think it has some good
ones they got there's a penguin there on
orbit yeah that's sweet right there and
then I don't know what is that an email
yeah
zipline ziplining yeah that was nothing
for them here's a book I don't know why
people don't like it but I guess it
didn't sell
white people ruining things you love
[Applause]
sorry I don't even know we were in that
book you know you know those bird
scooters that you see all over the place
now most grateful bird scooters look at
this book it's called carelessly
discarded bird scooters oh boy really
bad place actually terrible just who
would leaves leave a bird scooter in a
base path then right here that's just
Wow see dangerous yes and then I feel
really bad for this guy right here I
mean guys just trying to add his sooo
lunch
yeah that's not right oh look at this
one American Girl dolls turning the
tables they finally get Caitlyn make
they get to push it American Girl girl
is getting too pushed around real kid
how do you like it how do you see then
this one right over here
that's right crowd crouching bummed out
by Photoshop yeah this is a really
strange title it's just called
what's with the pineapple I mean it's
just it's it's after though yeah what's
going on in what's with the pineapple
now look the crowd isn't going for this
book right go and just plow through but
I think if we show them more they're
gonna really start to love this bit see
you know we actually have a rehearsal
and wheat some don't make it through but
this one did right right we thought that
was a winner
there were worse ones than this right
but you're not gonna see right and I
said no no let's give this one a shot
and then you the customer said no no no
dog daydreams this tells you what dogs
are daydreaming
[Applause]
man or yeah there's another one and then
this one worries me Wow even dogs
you